-The early 1980s saw the rise of
an exciting new rock genre
called new wave, and one duo was
at the forefront.
Roland Orzabal and Curt Smith
and their band, Tears for Fears.
In 1985, Tears for Fears
released their album
"Songs from the Big Chair,"
which included the smash hit,
"Head Over Heels."
With iconic melodies and
thoughtful lyrics, the track
would live on as one of the
great rock songs of all time.
But America never heard
its first draft until now.
♪♪
♪ -I wanted to be
with you alone ♪
♪ Talk about the weather ♪
♪ There's rain up in Seattle ♪
♪ So if you're going out ♪
♪ You might need an umbrella ♪
-♪ Got a degree in meteorology ♪
♪ To talk about the weather ♪
♪ According to the dew point,
the humidity's up ♪
♪ As the temperatures climb ♪
♪ That's just, just,
just summertime ♪
♪ For the weather, you can call
Tears for Fears ♪
♪ We'll check the radar ♪
♪ If the skies will be clear ♪
♪ Warm front's coming
so the clouds disappear ♪
♪ With a gentle breeze ♪
♪ 80 degrees, let's, let's look
at the four-day ♪
♪♪
♪ Forecast four days ♪
♪ After the sportscast
then the forecast begins ♪
♪ And we'll talk about
the weather ♪
♪ There's low fog overnight
so if you go for a walk ♪
♪ You, you, you, you might
need a sweater ♪
-♪ Cold air is rising,
forming cumulus clouds ♪
♪ That's barometric pressure ♪
♪ But the jet stream moves
the clouds out ♪
♪ By your morning commute ♪
♪ Oh, you'll feel the sun ♪
♪♪
♪ And this is
my four-day forecast ♪
♪ Look at the map,
don't need an app ♪
♪ This is my four-day forecast ♪
-♪ Da, da-da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da-da-da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da, da-da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da-da-da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da, da, da, da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da, da-da, Doppler ♪
♪ Da-da-da, Doppler ♪
-♪ Looks like blue skies ♪
-♪ Da, da, da, da, Doppler ♪
-♪ One little cloud
and the weather is nice ♪
-♪ Da-da-da, Doppler ♪
-♪ Funny how sun shines ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]